وفي بروكسيل يجتمع قاده الدول الاعضاء في
مجموعه اليورو لبحث السياسات الماليه
للاتحاد الاوروبي ووضع العمله لدى الدول
الاعضاء وكان اليوم الاول في القمه قد خصص
لتقييم الوضع في اوكرانيا حيث اعلن فيه بل
اعلن فيه القاده عن تزويد اوكرانيا بذخيره
للمدفعيه كما جددوا مطالبتهم روسيا بوقف
مصر وعدوانها وسحب جميع قواتها العسكريه
وكلائها من كامل اراضي اوكرانيا داخل
حدودها المعترف بها دوليا
ضموا الينا من مقر المجلس الاوروبي في
بروكسيل المراسل الجزيره نور الدين بوزيان
البارحه كان لبحث الحرب الاوكرانيه اليوم
هو بحث الماليه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
باجتماعي قادتها ماذا يتداولون فيه
يتداولون النقاط الخلافيه تحديدا التي
يقال بانها لم تحسم في محادثات ومفاوضات
ومشاورات امس اليوم هو شان اقتصادي محض
خاصه في ضوء ما حدث من زلزال بين ظفرين
لبعض البنوك البنك السويسري لتحديدا سويس
وايضا البنك الامريكي
في قبل اسبوعين التطمينات واضحه قبل هذه
الجلسه المخصصه لوضع منطقه اليورو سلمى
بشكل كبير بحيث ان رئيسه البنك الاوروبي
طمانه
الاوروبيين عندما قالت باننا استخلصنا
الدروس مما حدث في تلك الازمه البنكيه
العالميه التي حدثت في العام 2008 وان
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان صح التعبير كما قالت
نفسه بعده اليات تجعل البنوك الاوروبيه في
منى من اي هزه او خضه او زلزال لكن مع ذلك
يقول بعض الخبراء بان الدول الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي وضعها او بنوكها ليست مئه في
المئه في منى من اي تطور النقطه الخلافيه
الاخرى البارزه والتي ربما ستؤثر بشكل
كبير ربما على القاطره الاوروبيه التي كما
تعلمين يعني مشكله من المانيا وفرنسا هي
الخلاف حول تمويل الطاقات البديله وخاصه
الخلاف حول النووي فرنسا كما تعلمين تريد
الان ان
تفرض على الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يمول مشروع
اقامه بعض المحطات النوويه النظيفه بينما
المانيا ترفض ذلك وتقول لا يجب ان يمول
الاتحاد الاوروبي اشياء في الذاكره الجم
عيه للاوروبيين هي خطر في اشاره الى
النووي بصيغته التقليديه هناك ايضا خلاف
حول موضوع السيارات او خلاف امريكي اوروبي
تعرفين جيدا انه في المده الاخيره الاداره
الامريكيه قررت وضع 400 مليار دولار يعني
تعزيز
الصناعات النظيفه وهذا يقلق كثيرا الاتحاد
الاوروبي نور الدين مراسلنا شكرا لك